>> Sean: MIDTERMS JUST A WEEK
AWAY.
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS THAT MAKE
THIS MIRROR TO MY COUNTRY GREAT
ALL OF THE BALANCE.
DUE PROCESS, PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, OUR ECONOMY, OUR
SAFETY OR SECURITY.
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM, OHIO ATTORNEY GENERAL
RUNNING FOR THE GOVERNORSHIP OF
OHIO.
MIKE, THIS IS AN IMPORTANT RACE
FOR THIS REASON.
PEOPLE FORGET THESE GOVERNORS
RACES.
2020 WE GET THE SENSES AND THEN
YOU GET ALL THE REALIGNMENT,
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS BEGIN TO
CHANGE AND THEN REWRITE WHAT THE
DISTRICTS ARE IN USUALLY THE
PARTY IN POWER HAS GREATER SAY.
>> IT'S AMAZING HOW MUCH MONEY
IS BEING POURED INTO THE STATE
FROM THE DEMOCRAT SIDE.
THEY REALLY RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE GOVERNORSHIP
IN 2020.
THEY GET IT, SO WE SEE MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS COMING
FROM CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF OHIO.
>> Sean: SENATOR, YOU NOW
HAVE -- I WOULD ARGUE KAVANAUGH
WAS A TIPPING POINT.
THAT MOMENT DOESN'T HAPPEN I'M
NOT SURE HE GOT THROUGH.
IT YOU TO THE RIGHT THING,
CLEAR, MORAL, THE JUSTICE AND
INDIGNATION AND USE BOTH FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
ARE YOU NOW HAVE BEEN IN A LOT
OF STATES.
I DON'T KNOW WHO'S BUSIER, THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS 11 STOPS
BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
I THINK YOU HAVE PROBABLY AS
MANY.
>> HE'S GOT A BETTER PLAN, I CAN
TELL YOU THAT.
>> Sean: TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
RESONATING.
IMMIGRATION?
NOT WANTING TO GIVE CRUMBS BACK?
THE DEMOCRATS DESIRE TO IMPEACH.
OPEN BORDERS.
THE KAVANAUGH EFFECT?
>> KAVANAUGH AND THE CARAVAN.
IF YOU'RE REPUBLICAN AND YOU'RE
NOT EXCITED ABOUT VOTING, YOU'RE
LEGALLY DEAD.
KAVANAUGH WAS AN ASSAULT ON
EVERYTHING WE HOLD NEAR AND
DEAR.
THIS HAS BEEN A NIGHTMARE FOR
RED STATE TRUMP DEMOCRATS
BETWEEN THE KAVANAUGH DEBACLE,
DESPICABLE CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION AND A CARAVAN
TRYING TO OVERRUN OUR BORDERS.
WHETHER YOU ARE A BUSH
REPUBLICAN, TRUMP REPUBLICAN,
VEGETARIAN REPUBLICAN, YOU WERE
UPSET ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE DOING
TO BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THEY TRIED TO DESTROY THIS MAN'S
LIFE.
TO HOLD UP IN THE SEAT SO THEY
COULD FILL IT.
THEY DO NOT RECOGNIZE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON THE ELECTION
AND HE CHOSE A QUALIFIED PERSON
AND IT IS RESONATING ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY.
IT HAS UNITED REPUBLICANS.
IT HAS PUT DEMOCRATS ON THE
DEFENSIVE.
>> Sean: ON THE ISSUE OF
MEXICO, I KNOW YOU GOT THE
ATTENTION OF THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT YESTERDAY WITH YOUR
COMMENTS.
>> I DID.
I'M ABOUT TO GET IT AGAIN IF YOU
WILL GIVE ME 30 SECONDS.
>> Sean: GO AHEAD.
>> I APPRECIATE THE PHONE
CALL -- THEY DO WATCH FOX NEWS.
THANK YOU, MR. AMBASSADOR, FROM
MEXICO, CALLING ME.
I LIKE WHAT YOU SAY TO ME.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP THIS
CARAVAN AWAY FROM THE
UNITED STATES BORDER.
WE CAN WORK ON FIXING THE
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES, MAKE THEIR
LIVES BETTER AND WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO SECURE BOTH SIDES OF
THE BORDER WHAT YOU NEED TO STOP
THIS CARAVAN.
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID TO ME
AND KEEP WORKING WITH TOM.
I THINK YOU WILL BE A GOOD ALLY.
>> Sean: IF WE LOOK AT OHIO,
NO REPUBLICAN HAS EVER WON THE
PRESIDENCY WITHOUT WINNING YOUR
STATE AND IT IS TRULY A SWING
STATE.
TWO TIMES VOTED FOR OBAMA.
VOTES FOR DONALD TRUMP.
EVEN WITH THE HOSTILITY I WOULD
CALL IT OF JOHN KASICH, BUT AS
THE ECONOMY SINCE DONALD TRUMP
HAS BEEN PRESIDENT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF OHIO AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY HOW DO YOU HELP IT?
>> WE WOULD MOVE FORWARD.
CERTAINLY MOVE FORWARD UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF YOU GO BACK EIGHT YEARS ON MY
OPPONENT RICHARD CORDRAY WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND TED
STRICKLAND WAS THE GOVERNOR, WE
HAD LOST 400,000 JOBS.
DOUBLE DIGIT UNEMPLOYMENT.
THINGS WERE GOING SOUTH.
TODAY WE'VE REGAINED THOSE
400,000 JOBS, PLUS 150,000 OTHER
JOBS THIS PAST YEAR.
IN SEPTEMBER TO SEPTEMBER.
WE GAINED MORE JOBS, NEW JOBS
FOR THE STATE OF OHIO THEN WE'VE
HAD FOR 21 YEARS.
SO WERE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS GO
BACK TO THE TAX --